précédant l'annoncé prochaine de sa
déchéance par le conseil constitutionnel
bernard tapie a annoncé aujourd'hui
qu'il renonçait à son mandat de député
des bouches du rhône bernard tapie reste
cependant parlementaire européen ce qui
devrait lui assurer encore un certain
temps
l'immunité précision fille boisserie en
boxe cela s'appelle jeter l'épongé pour
éviter la déchéance de son mandat de
député national que le conseil
constitutionnel devait prononcer dans
les jours à venir
bernard tapie préfère renoncer le député
de gardanne dans les bouches du rhône ne
devrait plus l'être dès mercredi
car dès mercredi sort homme femme mode
d'emploi le film de lelouch dans lequel
il joue un avocat d'affaires pour
bernard tapie on ne peut pas être en
même temps artistes de cinéma est partie
prenante dans la vie politique nationale
donc dit-il
ils n'étaient pas sains que je reste
député un beau principe matinée quand
même d'une petite entorse tapis demeure
député européen
la procédure de déchéance à strasbourg
est plus incertaine
et puis renoncé à 70 milles francs
d'indemnité parlementaire mensuel ce
serait ne pas avoir le sens des affaires
c'est quoi avoir le sens des affaires le
son
dans son contrat d'acteurs bernard tapie
a trouvé une réponse plus précise il ne
sera pas payé par cachet qui pourrait
être saisie afin de rembourser ses
dettes mais touchera une participation à
partir de là 35 millièmes entrée sur
chaque billet payé un peu moins de 3
francs reviendront dans son escarcelle
de quoi voir l'avenir avec sérénité si
dantec la justice n'existait pas car
d'ici la fin de l'année
la cour de cassation doit se prononcer
sur sa condamnation dans l'affairé va om
si elle l'a confirme bernard tapie se
retrouva pour huit mois en prison